[Musik]
kurz sagen das macht das auch keinen
fall zu hause nach bestelle ich nicht an
drachen macht nur das was in der
beschreibung steht dass man sich ganz
ehrlich sagen der spuk nicht automatisch
teuer also an die kleinen von euch dort
mehr genommen dort mehr gedacht hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ja leute
manchmal ist einfach so ich sitze hier
abend und habe einfach nichts zu tun
keiner hier und theoretisch könnte ich
auch jeden abend ein cooles video drehen
müssen irgendwie einfach die denn ich
habe mir jetzt letztes irgendwie
überlegt ja so ein haustier wär schon
was cooles aber ich weiß nicht wo ich
einst herbekommen soll und ich will auch
nicht so etwas langweiliges haben was
jeder hat diesen hund oder eine katze
hamster oder meerschweinchen oder ein
pinguin hat nicht jeder das wäre echt
verdammt coole ich meine jeden abend
hast du wählen der die zone zwar nicht
antworten kann aber dem einzuhalten und
mit dem man spielen kann also richtig
gerne sachen wirklich so ein baby drache
das wär was ich solle mir einen drachen
im internet bestellen
ok
ich will alles raus hier einen drachen
es gibt es ja echt 70 euro ach komm 12
hundertstel vom placement in den
warenkorb und bestellt geil
leute mit stolz präsentiere ich euch nun
ich weiß gar nicht denn so schreibt auf
jeden fall jetzt schon mal alle einen
namen in die kommentare die ich ihnen
nennen soll falls ihr die heutige folge
überlegt absurd er hat sogar namen er
heißt hier
tor tor durch die leute jetzt fakt ich
wahrscheinlich wie so habe ich mir das
gestellt ich habe das letztens durch
zufall gefunden obwohl ihr habt mir die
sowie dahinter einstellung gehört der
hat mich so angegrinst ich musste den
einfach bestellen also eigentlich heißt
der torschrei bitte alle meine
kommentare wie der heißen soll und ich
überlegte mir für die heutige folge
folgenden namen m ctx i 1 c
wir nennen ihn einfach für heute mister
mz regal so leute jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob ich das aber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der fühlt sich liebl school an know hows
fast jeder youtube hat immer irgendeine
coole figuren seinen videos und das ist
meine die ja was die liste spitze
eingepackt gibt es auch so was wie eine
anleitung gibt heute das ist ab 4
genau das richtige für mich das ist so
voller frechheit oder ich habe mir
diesen drachen bestellt und da sind
nicht mal batterien weil ohne spaß wollt
ihr mich verarschen youtube so einen
scheiß daran denkt sich jedoch einig hat
solche batterien zu hause oder was okay
leute mir bleibt nichts anderes übrig
ich muss jetzt erstmal batterien kaufen
sechseinhalb stunden später war wieder
so leute herzlich willkommen zurück
ich habe jetzt gerade erst mal in ruhe
fußball geguckt musste mich etwas
beruhigen musste noch die eine oder
andere batterie kaufen ich habe den puck
von dem jetzt mal aufgeschraubt das ist
aber auch so gut wie batterien ein genau
in seiner auf jeden fall ist mein
mitbewohner jetzt sagt er hilft mir ein
bisschen unter der bedingung dass der
jetzt nicht mehr
mister fc-coach heißt sondern was ist
wie gesagt nein
wenn wir nicht lernen steht bei allen
daumen hoch wenn er der held denn manche
dass wir sie dann fehlt ja heißt jetzt
mal ein schritt helfen aber er schreibt
weiter den namen die kommentare so jetzt
passt mal auf jetzt stecken wir den mann
treten mal ein paar batterien im popo
damit auch mal an geht heute noch ich
hoffe weiter geht überhaupt an
bist du bereit so leute das haben wir
heute wären heute den 27 september
das torch geburtstag ist der 27
september nach dem motto heute genannt
[Musik]
magst du mich hasst sie gehört worden
er hat gerade das ist mir heute schaut
euch den mal an ist echt ein richtig
richtig süßes drache willst du
vielleicht irgendwie was man zuschauen
sagen also wie riechen meine zuschauer
so wie riechen meine zuschauer so gut
oder so und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
was da noch so kann hier haben was am
knopf hat er hat der busen
manfred so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ist das was macht so dass solche
maßnahme sein leben seine letzte spiel
war jetzt mach mal irgendwas mach mal
was und schmeckt ja frei
der fall so wir tun jetzt einfach mal so
als hätte man schnell aufgegessen kampa
lecker ja aber ich meine erste sein es
ist ja ein drachen ist zwar noch ein
baby drache aber er muss ja irgendwie
was können er muss ja wenigstens
vorsprung können kannst du vorhast und
manfred kurz kommt so leute passen
überhaupt wir testen jetzt mal was
passiert wenn wir drauf drücken
[Musik]
doch was ist das
ich stell dir vor das wäre einfach
vorher das letzte geil so du sprichst
feuer
vielleicht muss man auch eine woche
wartet und spuckte er ist guckt mich an
du spuckt feuer ist ein bisschen was
kommen wird das wiederholt was ist das
ich habe das gefühl jetzt guckt der
feuer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jung hatte vorerst vorbei
[Musik]
was ich kurz sagen was macht das auch
keinen fall zu hause nach bestellt euch
nicht an drachen macht nur das was in
der beschreibung steht dass man sich
ganz ehrlich sagen der spuk nicht
automatisch teuer also haben die kleinen
von euch dort mehr genommen dort nach
[Musik]
farbiger manfred du bist der wald gehört
auch meine männer sind in washington ein
der soll doch überlegen weil wir
aufgeben lasst ihn jetzt in ruhe platz
inneren ruhe das ist mein haus hier mit
dem kann ich abends hier in ruhe reden
und du wirst jetzt irgendwo fertig mit
der welt ich glaube es nicht gibt es ja
gar nicht
das hat der arme uci nur mit dir gemacht
blödmann uns das hier kriegt erst mal
machen
ja natürlich hoffe er dass spaß und ich
konnte euch mein neues haustier ein
bisschen näher bringen schreibt auf
jeden fall nahm in die kommentare
lasst für die aktion auf jeden fall
einen fetten daumen nach oben da ich
schon mal gespannt vielleicht schaffen
wir ja 15.000 lights und schreibt in die
kommentare wie wir den nennen sollen mal
sehen was wir so alles kommt bleibt den
kommentar der euch am besten gefällt
also der name der euch am besten gefällt
und damit jetzt denke ich mal öfter in
videos vorkommen checkt auf jeden fall
als letzter gemacht schon noch mal bei
jurij vermeidet fast 20.000 abonnenten
haben stört bei 20.000 feli und max
okay okay das mache und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder viel zu neues video
[Musik]